hey guys it's vadim with maxtec and you
have no idea how excited i am because
apple just sent out invites for their
october 18th event where we're expecting
apple to reveal a product that will
revolutionize the entire computer
industry yes i'm talking about the m1x
macbook pros that i've been waiting for
since literally the day that apple
released the m1 chip in november of last
year when i realized that the m1 was the
efficiency chip and not the performance
focus chip well in less than a week we
are getting that m1x performance chip
and it is gonna blow your mind so in
this video i'm gonna go through
everything that apple is likely to
reveal at this upcoming event as well as
my predictions for the machines that
will actually be released alongside this
new chat so let's get started with a
look at the event invite itself the
title is simply unleashed this is
obviously referring to apple unleashing
the m1x chip which is gonna be the most
powerful laptop chip ever made as i'm
gonna show you guys in just a minute and
this is why the graphic in the invite
looks like a warp drive effect flying
through space similar to something you'd
see from star trek and just to add some
more evidence to that claim when apple
released the m1 ship their newsroom
article back in november was literally
titled apple unleashes m1 so the
similarities are huge now with that said
let me go through some of the biggest
leaks and rumors that back up the
predictions of these m1x max coming next
week first off mark german who was the
most reliable apple leaker out there has
been saying for months that both the 14
and 16 inch m1x macbook pros are gonna
be revealed before the end of november
and very recently we've started to see
evidence of apple's current intel based
16-inch macbook pro running out of stock
at many apple stores around the nation
which usually only happens right before
the release of new models even better
the power adapters for macbook pros have
begun to run out of stock as well
pointing to apple releasing new charging
bricks for these m1x macbook pros which
is exactly what apple did for the m1
imac on top of that other leakers like
leaks apple pro and dylan dkt have
pointed to october as the month that
apple will reveal these new m1x macbook
pros and ross young a display analyst
that is extremely reliable someone who
perfectly nailed the display size for
the recent ipad mini 6 redesign is also
confident that apple will reveal new
macbook pros at this upcoming event and
imagine boo shared an image of a dvt
macbook pro unit with the chip showing
up as the m1x and those usually only
show up not too long before release
because dvt stands for design validation
test kind of like a quality control unit
and i myself am 100 sure that this is
gonna happen and i also believe the chip
will be called the m1x not the m2 and
not the m2x since i literally created
this t-shirt design that you guys can
buy if you want to help support this
channel and you can find it in the merch
shelf below so now before i get into the
other machines i expect to get released
alongside the new m1x chip i wanna dive
deep into the specs and features that
i'm expecting apple to pack into the new
chip itself according to mark german
it's gonna feature a 10 core cpu layout
specifically with eight performance
cores and just two efficiency cores
that's double the p cores and half the e
cores compared to the m1 which shows
that these chips will be focused on
performance so i estimated the
performance of this new chip compared to
the m1 and here is what i got around 15
000 multi-core points and geekbench 5
which outperforms every single laptop
chip ever made and it even outperforms
the 16 core xeon cpu in the mac pro this
will essentially blow the minds of
everyone in the tech industry but wait
until you see the estimates for the gpu
performance mark german believes there
is going to be two versions of the chip
one with a 16 core gpu and one with a 32
core gpu so here are the estimates that
i've made for the performance of these
two chips with even the base 16 core
model outperforming the insanely
powerful 5600m gpu in the current 16
inch macbook pro and the 32 core option
will outperform the very best dedicated
5700 xt gpu in the current 27 inch imac
which is insane for a gpu that's fully
integrated into the main chip so if you
want to see us test them out to the
extreme then subscribe right now because
as you might know we went all out on our
m1 mac coverage last year with the most
in-depth comparisons on the web now
apart from the cpu and the gpu mark
german claimed that it would have up to
64 gigabytes of unified memory which is
controversial since others like luke
miyani have reported that it's going to
be limited to 32 gigs but either way
it'll be enough for almost everyone and
finally mark german said that it's gonna
come with an improved neural engine and
this is where i get into what i think
the m1x chip is gonna be based on in my
opinion i believe it's gonna be based on
the five nanometer plus a15 chip that we
just got in the iphone 13 for a few
different reasons first off since these
macbook pros are focused on performance
it makes sense for apple to use the
latest and highest clocked cores in the
m1x chip and as we know the a15 chip
features gpu cores that are quite a bit
faster than the ones in the m1 and on
top of that the new efficiency cores in
the a15 are a lot faster than the old
ones as well which means that they can
handle more tasks on their own without
having to even turn on the performance
cores for some workloads which helps
save battery life so if apple uses these
new faster efficiency cores in the m1x
it would completely explain why apple
made the weird choice to use only two of
these efficiency cores compared to the
previous four since they're going to be
more powerful than before now matching
up to mark german's leak the new a15
chip has a new faster neural engine and
i expect that to go directly into the
m1x alongside all the other new
components like the image signal
processor and the new video encoders and
decoders including the new ones that are
meant for prores so yeah with all that
said the m1x chip is gonna be insane and
i personally think that this chip will
blow the minds of the entire tech
industry and it's gonna put shivers down
the spines of every windows laptop
company out there essentially forcing
them to switch to arm and risk five base
chips because of the massive battery
life benefits now getting into the
machines themselves the m1x ship will
definitely be going into both the 14 and
16 inch macbook pros as well as the
high-end mac mini and the larger imac
but i don't expect all of them to be
revealed at this event so before i
explain what i mean let's get into the
specs and features of the 14 and 16 inch
macbook pro according to main chakra and
mark german the macbook pro will feature
a new design with a flat bottom and top
similar to what you see on apple's
latest ipads now john prosser already
leaked the design of the m2 macbook air
redesign and i expect the m1x macbook
pros to look very similar just nowhere
near as thin and of course with more
ports specifically leaks are pointing to
them getting an sdxc card slot as well
as an hdmi port and a new magsafe
connector for charging they're also
going to be getting either three or four
thunderbolt 4 ports as well now as far
as the displays many leakers and
reporters agree that they're going to be
using mini led technology just like on
apple's 12.9 inch ipad pro which is
going to make watching videos and movies
look so much better than before now ross
young believes that apple is actually
going to include 120hz pro motion
technology with these new macbook pros
which is literally a game changer now i
personally found it a bit hard to
believe that apple would give it 120
hertz this year but then a twitter user
reminded me that mac os monterey
actually supports adaptive sync external
displays on newer macs this by itself is
a huge hint at apple giving the m1x
macbook pros 120 hertz pro motion
displays because promotion is
essentially apple's version of adaptive
sync technology and as we know mac os
monterey is going to be launching
alongside the new macbook pros so
everything is lining up going further
dylan dkt believes that the displays
will have smaller bezels without a logo
on the bottom as well as a 1080p webcam
and new charging bricks now i fully
agree with all of these details because
i personally believe that the display
will feature rounded corners like on the
ipad pro making it easier to pack in
thinner bezels and i believe this
because the latest versions of mac os
have rounded windows on both the top and
the bottom and as far as the removal of
the macbook pro logo on the bottom of
the display this perfectly matches up to
john prosser's leak of the redesigned
macbook air which also showed these new
long rubber pads on the bottom which i'm
expecting to come to the m1x macbook
pros since the current m1 imac uses this
new pad design now on top of that the
display resolutions have recently leaked
for both the 14 and 16 inch macbook pros
and they actually reveal a new more boxy
and tall aspect ratio directly pointing
to apple getting rid of that bottom chin
and logo and as far as the new charging
bricks i expect them to be smaller than
before featuring a usb type-c port so
you can either charge with the included
magsafe adapter cable or a regular usb
type-c cable we should also expect the
touch bar to finally get removed and i
fully agree with luke miani's leak about
the circular backlit touch id button
from the new magic keyboard to come to
the m1x macbook pros as well as the
newer shortcut keys for spotlight search
microphone do not disturb and the
language
emoji key now with that said everything
that i just mentioned will be coming to
both the 14 and 16 inch macbook pros so
let me go through the differences i
expect for each model this 16 inch will
be coming with a faster charging brick
better speakers a better cooling system
due to the larger size and obviously a
larger 100 watt hour battery pack i'm
personally expecting apple to announce
up to 20 hours of battery life for the
14 inch and 25 or 30 hours of battery
life for the 16 inch which will blow
everyone away so here is a list of specs
for both the 14 and 16 inch m1x macbook
pro models including the specs features
and prices for the standard models and
as you can see i expect the 32 core gpu
option to be exclusive to the 16 inch
model now moving on to the other
machines that will be getting this new
chip i personally expect the m1x mac
mini to be revealed at this event just
like i claimed two months ago and i
fully expect the design to match the
renders by john prosser and ian zelbo so
here is a list of all the specs and
features i'm expecting including the
price and chip options now i personally
think that the m1x 30-inch imac is
likely not coming for a few months
because there is going to be too many
macs screaming for attention if they
reveal all of them at once at this event
so apple will likely do the same thing
they did with the m1 24 inch imac and
reveal it a few months later so it can
be the center of the spotlight now
finally dylan dkt also believes that the
airpods 3 will be revealed or released
at this event which i can totally see
happening but other than that there's
one more thing that could end up being
released and that's a nintendo switch
style hybrid gaming console which has
actually been leaked for many months
through various sources this new
handheld gaming device will also be able
to connect to external tvs and monitors
and there's a chance that apple is
creating a new gpu-focused chip
specifically for this new gaming device
now i actually went through all of the
details and this video that i made
almost half a year ago but the rumors
are still the same so check it out if
you want all of the details now if apple
releases this new gaming device they
will also be making a huge push into
gaming across all of their products
especially the new m1x macbook pros with
new crossplay features so you can play
online with anyone who has an apple
device but to wrap up this entire video
you guys are about to witness history
with the release of the m1x macbook pro
with the entire computing industry
beginning the shift away from
traditional x86 chip designs including
intel themselves so hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you're excited
for this event go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe right now
because we're going to be covering these
macs more than any channel out there so
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]